Shops in the Venezuelan capital smashed up
and picked clean of their contents...
At this supermarket in southeastern Caracas,
people accused of taking food including pasta,
rice and tomato sauce were among those later
arrested by security forces for looting.
Scenes of desperation like this are becoming
more commonplace in the crisis-hit South American
nation... compounded by a days-long power
outage.
Medicines were already in short supply.
Now reports that the blackout has led to patients
dying in hospitals are also fuelling rising
anger at the government's inaction.
The crisis in Venezuela has a first and last
name and it is Nicolas Maduro ((... )) It's
time to understand that the humanitarian crisis
is not a political crisis, it is a social
crisis.
Venezuelans are dying because there are no
solutions."
Meanwhile those fortunate enough to get power
from a generator are finding new uses for
their refrigerators.
We have a refrigerator where we're storing
food, but it can also fit some medicines.
There are a lot of people that need to store
them in refrigeration, at least as far as
insulin is concerned.
But many businesses have been without power
for days.
With their fridges off - food is rotting on
the shelves, forcing many shop-owners to cut
their losses.
I'm giving this all away . Yesterday I gave
away pizza.
Today I'll give all this to the kids on the
street.
As the crippling blackout drags on, so does
the blame game between the opposition and
the president.
All Venezuelans can do for now is wait for
good news.